what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future which is someone off
like my lemons face god I get excited
during injustice covers my dog Max is
excited during injustice cows god I love
injustice coming okay so here's the
beauty of injustice really like the
first the first injustice line of
stories here's 1.5 the beauty of this is
that we got some crazy moments room was
like just attack everything let's just
destroy it it was like these really cool
moments but at the same time we also got
like these these great moments that were
kind of tender and they deal with the
nature of the characters and so on and
so forth but the cool thing about
injustice too is it builds on that but
it also takes this question this idea of
who is the fake Batman now my personal
opinion I did the fake Batman is Red
Hood I asked you guys that question in
the last video and I was like would you
like who do you think to think Batman is
I'm like most people were like it's
probably Jason Todd like I mean I don't
know why it wouldn't be is a fake Batman
Jason Todd just like clickbait the hell
out of the title I have no idea but the
fact remains here that this is an
insanely great story because this deals
with two different things one it deals
with the daughter of Harley Quinn and
two it deals with Damian Wayne
because remember Damien Wayne was this
character were a lot of ways with the
injustice line of stories at least the
first injustice line of stories DC was
just relying on our existing knowledge
of Damian Wayne from just the main line
new 52 line of stories you know for DC
in order to kind of fill in the gaps in
terms of what his characters backstory
was what his whole history was what his
training regimen had been like we got
little you know bits and pieces here and
there but for the most part it was you
know who Damian Wayne is from the new 52
we're just gonna roll a man and call it
a day it worked because we got to see
some great evolution with his character
was focusing more on the moment that it
was you know later in the future and
we'll talk more about that once we get
to him but the cool thing about this is
that we deal with the immediate
aftermath of the mission to try to
basically grab Superman or to take out
Batman because remember we have this
fake Batman running around and the idea
was that he had essentially created his
own Suicide Squad you know Amanda Waller
had her own squad this fake Batman
showed up killed her on the spot killed
the unofficial members of the team and
then turned around and
made the neighbor was left to the
Suicide Squad into his own group but the
implication here in this conversation
between Harley Quinn and Floyd Lawton
the guy that we know as Deadshot this
conversation here basically reveals the
Batman this fake Batman is not running
on his own he's not doing his own thing
he's working for someone and that's what
makes this so cool because it's one of
these things were it's like he's working
for someone is the person he's working
for working for someone then what does
that mean does that mean that the person
that he's working for it's ultimately
going to die he's just going to become
as you know Batman is going to become
his own leader and there's a lot of
questions to be asked with the story
going later on down the line well what
is up happening here is this big Batman
basically is it taking Harley Quinn the
rest of the Suicide Squad over to meet
his employer who's basically revealed to
be Ra's al Ghul now here's the coolest
thing about this Ra's al Ghul and he's
depicted in the injustice line of
stories is classic Ra's al Ghul and
really the motivations behind his
character the basic the you know the
basis behind his existence is actually
something that's kind of been lost in
the storytelling of his character over
the course of years when it comes to DC
Comics for the most part
whenever Ra's al Ghul shows up people
think of like the classic moments of his
character so like him stealing the
Justice League protocols from Batman in
the story tower Babel and then using
those protocols against the Justice
League they'll usually think of these
moments about what his character is
really about Ra's al Ghul is just a
crazy eco-terrorist that's all he is
he's just a guy who believes that
humanity is like poisoning the
environment different things like that
and the goal is to basically eliminate
humanity in its entirety and to allow
the natural stage of evolution which in
Ra's al Ghul's mind is basically anybody
not corrupting the environment allows
them to sort of proliferate and to keep
things in check now again one of the
reasons why I see kind of back seated
this whole thing when it came to like
this part of his life is because it's a
lot more interesting to have Ra's al
Ghul fight to Justice Li because he's a
bad guy as opposed to him just like
wanting to save the environment but it's
kind of a cool thing because you look at
a guy with so much power and you look at
a guy with so many resources and you're
just kind of like and all he wants to do
is just fight on behalf of the plants
like isn't that what poison ivy supposed
to be doing or is it that what Swamp
Thing is supposed to be doing and indeed
the popularity of those characters the
more they grew in popularity in the eyes
of DC fans the more it made sense to
have them in the limelight the more it
makes sense the half
an IV out there the more made sense to
have swampthing out there to have them
as the ones fighting the fight on behalf
of the environment not only that
remember the whole idea of poison ivy
and and in Harley Quinn having had a
relationship still seems to be intact
and even if they weren't really in a
relationship together they're still very
close friends so again it's one of those
things that Tom Taylor really seems to
toy on in terms of their backstory what
they mean to each other and all that
kind of good stuff
but ultimately what is up happening here
is that the questions more less raised
about the choices of Harley Quinn
because remember whenever you're
inducted into the Suicide Squad a bomb
is planted into your head and either you
can do what the Suicide Squad tells you
to do or you can die and what Ra's al
Ghul's basically saying is we're going
to basically initiate this campaign what
do we use the resources of Superman
we're going to basically commit genocide
now this is kind of cool the idea of
Harley over the course of injustice
years one through five the first line of
stories going to injustice queue was
basically character Redemption it's very
easy for riders to come along and like
assassinate characters right like is
very easy for either has to come along
and say yeah see like Harley Quinn isn't
corrigible she cannot be saved it didn't
work that way instead we just got like
all these little tidbits these little
goodies about her character
over the course of the story that she
had a daughter that we didn't know
anything about you know that she
basically had to leave her daughter
behind so her daughter would never get
swept up in the life of Harley Quinn
there despite the fact that she knew she
had a child ultimately her ties were to
the Joker and really one of Harley's
biggest fears was it that the Joker ever
found out she had a daughter or if the
Joker realized that Harley Quinn was
going to leave the Joker for her
daughter it might result in the Joker
killing her daughter and so again it
created like these really intertwining
personal relationships but over the
course on injustice years one through
five Harley Quinn went from just this
crazy sadist sidekick of the Joker to
becoming a character that was redeemed
the character that we loved as it was
all about this Redemption you know
making her something interesting making
her something more unique her whole ties
with you know Green Arrow and so on it
was all just a great aspect of redeeming
her and making her something better and
so in this scenario when she says we're
not going to commit genocide the beauty
of this is that she's approaching it
from a reasonable human being dare I say
a sane human being instead of being
crazy and so again it's kind of cool
because Ra's al Ghul basically says yeah
I mean you could leave if you wanted
- we have to kill you and it would suck
I mean you probably don't care cuz you
wouldn't do anything terrible but your
daughter would really miss you and
that's a dangerous road to walk because
remember Molly Quinn's daughter is her
whole world she talks to her as often as
she can you know through phone calls
I mean Carly's daughter currently lives
with her sister but Ra's al Ghul
basically saying hey I mean you know if
you died your daughter would be really
sad when Maz al Ghul starts spinning out
these little tidbits about the kind of
things that Harley's daughter likes to
do we ultimately end up learning that
Ra's al Ghul has captured the daughter
of Harley Quinn and that's crazy because
now our daughters in the picture but not
only that it adds this danger to the
story right because now Harley is
fighting a war on two fronts the first
part of our war takes the form of okay
we got to make sure this crazy guy Ra's
al Ghul doesn't destroy humanity but the
other half is keeping your daughter safe
and if you have to choose one which one
are you going to choose the other half
of this is that Harley Quinn basically
says look you could very well like shoot
me if you wanted to you know or you
could shoot my daughter you know if you
chose to kill my daughter what do you
think is gonna happen do you think I'm
gonna side with you do you think you're
somehow going to sway my mind do you
think that somehow you're just gonna be
like oh it almost could be like oh my
god he killed my daughter well now I've
got to do what he wants me to do no no
you know Harley Quinn's gonna die trying
to stop Ra's al Ghul or even worse she's
going to successfully escape which means
then she's gonna have time to formulate
a plan and woe betide you if Harley
Quinn comes after you with a plan in
mind the idea is look you know what
you're trying to do here is inspire
loyalty and that's one of the cool
things when it comes to Ra's al Ghul's
character is because he's not usually in
a situation like this usually he's in a
situation where he's just running the
League of Shadows it's usually him just
just saying look you do what I tell you
to you and they say yes we do it's not
really this idea of like conflicting
opinions he's not really used to someone
standing out and saying no I'm not gonna
do where you tell me I don't really feel
like it I think it's kind of a stupid
idea he's used to just absolute control
and so when you suddenly have someone
like Harley Quinn coming in and say no
you know I'm doing my own thing I'm my
own game ultimately if there was a
wrench of the works because Roz is not
used to that now something else to point
out here is it Ron's in the injustice
universe it's not really as cruel as he
is in me in the main DC line of stories
because in the main DC line of stories
he probably would have shot Harley Quinn
and shot
and then said and I will kill all of you
and I will just kill everybody that you
know and then just get a new group of
people in here or just do it with my own
League of Assassins if you really want
to get in the way okay so because of the
fact that a lot of villains just being
in the position of self-preservation
they would probably get in there you
know probably give them they will
probably just say okay fine we'll do
what you tell us to for now you know and
that kind of a thing and that would be
the end of that Roz is expending every
olive branch of friendship here he's
literally believing that he's doing the
right thing and that's what's so
interesting because we're Harley Quinn
head button and Harley Quinn takes him
out ultimately poison ivy grabs her and
basically says look you can't do this
you can't go through this entire
position and just start attacking
everybody because despite the fact that
Ra's al Ghul will basically use this
nonsensical thing and said ah well you
know your daughter would really miss you
he's right and that's one of the crazy
things about this is because Harley
Quinn is acting as any mother would but
it's also heard as kind of being
emotional and being irrational in truth
her daughter does need her her daughter
does need someone to raise her because
what's the alternative I mean let's say
for example this played out let's say
for example that this resulted in Harley
Quinn just refusing to listen to poison
ivy and Harley Quinn just attacking Ra's
al Ghul and dying in the conflict well
that leaves her daughter without a
mother now either Ra's al Ghul's gonna
let this girl go back to the sister of
Harley Quinn to continue being raised in
whatever environment she was in but most
likely the daughter of Harley Quinn will
be adopted into the race of Ra's al Ghul
and be trained to become a prodigious
assassin any chance of her having a
reasonable transit would be gone in the
blink of an eye and so the idea of
Harley Quinn is to this we say look okay
fine if this is what it takes in order
to make sure that I can get out of this
line that my daughter and I can
basically leave and we can have some
measure of a life together then that's
what I'll do and that's ultimately what
is up happening here now it's not just
the the motivational words of poison ivy
that's why Harley Quinn it's also Harley
Quinn's own conscience and that's the
cool thing about this because this all
feeds back remember all of this started
because the Joker tricked Superman into
thinking that Lois Lane was doomsday
superman reacted just took lo you know
took doomsday into space only for the
the toxin you know the fear toxin to
wear off and for him to realize he just
killed his wife and his unborn child a
nuclear bomb in Metropolis was tied to
the heartbeat of Lois Lane when she died
the bomb went off and metropolis was
totally obliterated and so because of
Superman's own actions which he had been
tricked into committing by the you know
the junker Superman not only lost his
wife and unborn child
he lost everyone he ever knew in this
city of Metropolis his whole world
blinked out of existence in the fraction
of a second and so again Harley Quinn
had to look at this and say yeah she had
a hand in it she was part of this she
was one of the people that made this
happen and despite her efforts her road
to redemption Ra's al Ghul pits this
against her because we could be like the
the third party in her corner right like
I mean if we were in this comic unless
all of us would say no no I mean yeah
you did a terrible thing but look at
what you've done to make up for it you
are instrumental in bringing down
Superman's totalitarian regime you've
given back for what you've done and then
some but Ra's al Ghul's like look I need
this woman on my side I need her to my
cause sure you know I'll do whatever it
takes in order to pull this off and says
yeah you cannot make up for what it was
you initially did but you can try to
make up for it by siding with us and so
again ultimately Harley Quinn seems to
give in she seems to say okay and
effectively joins Ra's al Ghul now at
this point we switch over to what I
think is really one of the best parts of
the story with injustice - with the
first volume what we basically had is we
had the return of Black Canary and green
arrow remember during the first line of
injustice stories essentially Black
Canary had been killed so to speak by
Superman but the idea was at dr. fate
we've stepped in and said no we're going
to save your life I had to do at least
one good thing I have to somehow Act I
can't just let all this evil continue on
and so we basically took a black canary
saved her life
whisked her away to a different reality
where Green Arrow hadn't died and his
blackened area died and so what it
allowed dr. fate to do was to pair
together
Black Canary and Green Arrow Wood Green
Oh having his own son Connor Hawke and
so it was essentially Black Canary
treating that version of Oliver Queen as
if he's the Oliver Queen as she always
knew you know and they were basically
able to be raised as a family now of
course because of the events that are
going on with Superman escaping and
injustice - it ultimately led to the
idea of dr. fate grabbing Black Canary
and Oliver Queen from that universe
alongside their son and bringing them
back over to the injustice universe but
what does does is it brings in the third
party of Connor Hawke Connors like this
bit of innocence right I mean he's been
been trained by flection Terry he's been
trained by Oliver Queen but he haven't
seen everything that Batman seen over
the courses life he's not like Damian
Wayne and the
why this is so cool is because of the
fact that in the middle of his
conversation with connor hawke batman
has this flashback to the early days of
him training Damian Wayne and what is
happening here is that when Damian has
initially you know given the role of
Robin the question becomes is he capable
of going out on his own is he capable of
going out and being his own superhero
because remember in the Batman landscape
regardless of what era were talking
about whether it's before crisis on
Infinite Earths with Dick Grayson and
the first iteration of Jason Todd if
it's after crisis on Infinite Earths
with the second iteration of Jason Todd
going into like 10 Drake and Damian
Wayne and so on and so forth Batman
always puts them to task to see whether
or not they can hold it out there on
their own and it's not just a matter of
can they do it because they have the
strength to fight off different villains
can Damian Wayne be out there on his own
if like Killer Croc were to show up it's
also can he be out there on his own and
do the right thing and help the people
who need to be helped that's one of the
coolest things about this because what
ends up happening is batman takes damian
wayne to the furthest side to the part
of gotham city that's farthest away from
the Batcave telling him it takes three
hours to get from this point to the
Batcave without stopping and so if you
can pull that off if you can do that
then you'll be--you'll basically prove
that you can get out on your own now the
funny thing about this is that while
this is a time trial it's a moral trial
and that's one of the greatest things
about this because we get these little
tidbits of Damian Wayne we get these
little itty bitty you know introduction
aspects of his character and it's this
idea that Damian was a good guy and
again that's really what we see a lot
going on in like the mainline DC stories
you know whether it's classic DC before
the Newport is you DC during the new 52
its Damian Wayne basically redeeming
himself and injustice we didn't really
get that we got it in so far that he
realized that maybe Superman wasn't 100%
right but in the end ultimately sided
with Superman because he believed that
Bruce Wayne was not right any form of
fashion that humanity had to be
controlled and so again it was really
this idea of how did we get to that
point what happened to Damian Wayne in
the past that there was no chance for
redemption and what does really does is
it basically tells us did he had every
opportunity that he was a good guy
he shows up you know four minutes in any
station forgets bad guys who were trying
to mug a woman the woman gives him five
bucks this adorable kid says look we
can't really take money I mean we can't
really take my tips or anything but
ultimately she ends up giving him five
anyway half an hour in he talks a man
awful edge from killing himself and
shares coffee with him notice these
things about Damian Wayne notice the
character that's being portrayed here
he's a genuinely good kid he's doing the
best he can
he's helping those who were in need and
that's what's so great about this is
because it's like fast-tracking all the
redemption that we had in the mainline
DC stores and the mainline DC stores you
got to keep in mind it took you know
better than five years in order for
Damian William to gain some measure of
redemption for him to get from his
original introduction you know during
some of the bat you know the whole idea
of him being being just a trained killer
that had to be harnessed you know during
the son of backstory like all the way up
to right now in Teen Titans rebirth it
took years in order to pull that off
what we're getting here I think is more
impactful because it shows us him doing
the small things and ultimately it's the
small things that really show what
characters are capable of you know
there's a guy who stabbed Damian Wayne
brings him to the hospital there's an
old woman getting on a bus he gives you
know he carries her groceries and helps
her on and she ends up giving him a tip
a couple of guys try to rob or try to
commit a crime he drops them off in
front of the Gotham police station this
trip was supposed to take three hours
ends up taking ten hours and 47 minutes
and it's not because Damian Wayne's lazy
it's because he was doing all the right
things he was helping as many people as
he possibly could and in the face of
failure and the face of realizing that
when he got back that Batman would say
you failed this test he did it anyway
and that's why Jamie and Wayne is so
cool in the injustice line of stories
because of this idea that if he sets his
mind to task and if he says I'm going to
do the right thing and I don't care what
the consequences are then he will do
that and he will not worry about the
consequences translate this to the
original conflict between Batman and
Superman it makes sense that he would
take the stamps that he did it makes
sense that he would look around the
landscape and say okay who's really
right here Batman who says people should
have freedom even if it means that
freedom's going to lead to the
destruction of society as a whole or
Superman who says we're going to take
that freedom away and we're going to
save society from itself Damian Wayne
sided with Superman believing that he
was absolutely right knowing that he was
absolutely right Damian Wayne went with
it Damian Wayne what was his gut said
okay is Damian Wayne believe that
Superman is intrinsically
100% right where does Superman really
was or not
Damian Wayne believed that he was right
knew that he was right and sided with
Superman because of that this backs up
that decision this basically gives us an
explanation for why it was he did that
and that's why it's so cool because
we'll we end up finding out is that it
took Bruce Wayne three days to make it
to the city of Gotham at one point when
he went from that point all the way to
the Batcave it took three days for him
to pull it off because he was trying to
save everybody he could come across and
so again
that's why the original indication was
that well as a time trial it's a time
test you have to make it back in three
hours when in reality it was a moral
test will he do the right thing when he
doesn't believe anybody's watching it
and that's when that man says you can go
out on your own that was the test the
test was to see would you do the right
thing if you think no one's watching you
what will you do when when you believe
there's no eyes on you and Damian Wayne
did every single right thing and so
again it's really this great idea
because he officially steps into the
mantle of being Robin now of course
alfred being alfred the funny little
thing about this is alfred says look
Bruce Wayne like your dad will tell you
like there are times when you're going
to be out there on your own
and there's going to be nothing he can
do he's going to be watching you every
single time if we're no other reason
than to just make sure that you stay
safe so the cool thing about this is
that it becomes the fact that Damian
Wayne and those in the eyes of Bruce
Wayne had basically fallen from grace
because Damian Wayne you know really
kind of a path really started with him
accidentally killing Dick Grayson and
then ultimately falling down the path of
joining Superman because of the fact
that it all led to Damian Wayne and
Batman being at odds being enemies that
man looks at connor hawke as a chance to
start over he looks at kind of hawk as a
chance to do the right thing this time
around and so what we don't really know
what it is he's doing what we do know is
you basically approaches connor hawke
with some kind of a device and says you
can't tell your parents about this
whatever it is that we're doing is going
to be my little secret it's gonna be our
little secret between the two of us when
that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come let's explain
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the Robin course you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop unlike and yeah I will catch you
all later please
you
[Music]